hi
welcome welcome to this evening's
planning committee i think i've just
broken the gavel but doesn't matter
good evening members of the community
and members of public um i'd like to
welcome you to the
central area planning committee on the
15th of december 2021
my name is councillor jeanette stiltz
and i am the chairman for this meeting
the meet members the meeting for the met
for the meeting have been designed to
mitigate for covid therefore can i ask
all present to work to the protocol
agreed at council on the 2nd of
september 2021
in the interest of member and officer
safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded members and
officers during each item please put
your hand up to indicate if you wish to
speak i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can i ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished please
reference a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is at the
door behind the top table
i would also like
it noted that councillor morris is in
attendance
item two apologies for absence berna can
i have apologies for absence
and thank you chairman
we received apologies for absence from
councillor miss phil
and councillor lagan
thank you
bernard
item three on the agenda minutes it is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 17th of november
2021 found on pages seven to eight are
approved as a true and accurate record
i so move do i have a seconder for that
motion
thank you councillor mays
does any member wish to raise any matter
of accuracy
on those minutes
no
okay is every member happy to agree
these by ascent
thank you
item four on the in
on the agenda declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regrets to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need
arise throughout the meeting
counsellor
none yes thank you um as i've said
previously i'm acquainted with the um
history of the building and also with
the applicant uh but it's of a
non-pecuniary interest thank you
councillor mice
yes good evening uh madam chairman um
non-pecuniary interest in that i have
met with historic england on the site um
in between the applications thank you
councillor heard
um thank you chair not bicunary uh i'm
uh acquainted with one of the objectives
thank you councillor herd
if there's no other
declarations of interest we will move on
i will ask the
officers that are present to introduce
themselves just so that the public are
aware of who i have sitting on the table
with me
thank you chairman i am matthew lee lead
specialist place here at morgan district
council thank you
hi i'm hannah dungate development
management planning specialist
hi my name is alex taylor and i am the
senior specialist coordinator for
development management
thank you we re now moved to item five
on the agenda which is the report
for
house mail
2001
10 10 20 which is joshua 4 silver street
malden s6
and this is found on pages
9-26 miss dungate would you like to give
that report
yes thank you chairman
householder planning permission and
listed building consent is sought for
the restoration and alterations of the
exterior and interior of number four
silver street
this application follows a previously
refused application at this committee on
the 25th of august for a similar
development
the application is a revision to that
review scheme by removing any proposed
alterations to the seller and retention
of the existing carport at the side of
the property
this is the site location plan for the
application
as you can see
this high street is located south of the
site here
this is the existing block plan for the
site
and this is the proposed block pan for
the site
which shows the carport to be retained
here
the side porch to be removed here and
the replacement canopy at the rear here
also shown is the block plan of the
previously refused application
here which originally shows the carport
to be removed
this is the existing front elevation of
the property
this is the
proposed front elevation showing the
carport to be retained
also shown is the previously refused
application
which showed the carport to be removed
here
this is the existing rear elevation
and this is the proposed rear elevation
um
showing the replacement of the
dilapidated 20th
century conservatory with a canopy
um the removal of the
unsympathetic
side porch
um the removal of a late 20th century
window here
and you can also see that the carport is
also retained
here this is one of the existing side
elevations
and this is the proposed side elevation
again it shows the porch to be removed
here
as well as some replacement windows
and just to note all of the windows to
be replaced are unsympathetic late 20th
century windows of no historic
significance
and it is considered that the new
windows would be more in keeping with
the age and character of the property
this is the other side elevation
existing
and this is the proposed side elevation
which shows the canopy open sided canopy
and one new
bedroom window as well as other
replacement windows
this is the existing basement floor plan
and this is the proposed basement floor
plan
as you can see from comparison with the
previously refused scheme
um
there are no changes proposed to the
seller anymore including the removal of
the cellar doors
and any ventilation units to this floor
this is the existing ground floor plan
and this is the proposed ground floor
plan
as you can see
in comparison to the previously refused
scheme
this staircase to the seller is no
longer proposed
there is a new secondary staircase
proposed here
and
there are a number of
other changes including the removal of
some late 20th century partitions which
also possess no significance to the list
of building and the insertion of some
new internal walls
this is the ground floor ceiling plan
and this is the proposed ground floor
ceiling plan
this is the first floor plan of the
existing property
and this is the proposed first floor
plan
um
again the changes include the removal of
some late 20th century partitions which
possess no significance
and
the insertion of some new internal walls
these are existing section drawings and
proposed and they just show that the
changes to the seller are no longer
proposed
this is another existing section drawing
proposed section drawing showing the
staircase to the seller is no longer
proposed
in comparison to previous application
existing and proposed sections from the
front of the house showing the carport
to be retained
and just another existing section
and proposed section
this is an aerial photograph of number
four
silver street
and these are views of number four from
the street scene
and these are views of the rear of the
property showing the dilapidated
conservatory and the window to be
removed
these are side views of the property
showing
the unsympathetic
late sent late 20th century windows to
be replaced
and these are just some internal
photographs of the property
um so in line with the assessment
carried out within the committee report
the proposal would result in no harm to
the significance of the listed building
or the conservation area the amendments
to the proposal are considered to
overcome the previous refusal reason and
it should be noted that the proposal was
supported by historic england the
society for the protection of ancient
buildings and the council's conservation
and list of building specialists
it is noted that a number of concerns
have been raised in relation to the
potential change of use of the property
however it is important to note that the
application submitted and being assessed
within the committee report is for the
physical alterations to the dwelling not
to the change of use of the site
um it may be possible to rent the
dwelling out as is the case with any
other dwelling
without planning permission being
required however if a change of use was
to occur this would require further
planning permission as part of a further
application
um as such the application is
recommended for approval subject to
conditions thank you chairman thank you
members you have all had these
updated
um
notes before this meeting
we have one um public participation
as an objector for this application miss
woods would you like to
take a seat you have two minutes
this planning application is an
aggressive development and alteration on
a grade two star listed property
other listed building owners are
subjected to intense constant scrutiny
and a dictate of like for like in their
ongoing renovations
why these restrictions not being applied
to this property
these proposal proposals will impact on
the integrity of the building structure
a new staircase will require joists to
be cut and removed
window and door layout changes will
alter the visual appearance of three
elevations of the building and again
change the structure a fire protected
corridor goes far beyond domestic
dwelling requirement
if approved this application will set a
precedence for other listed property
owners
to apply for aggressive alterations and
development on their buildings in the
heart of this heritage town
the internal layout configuration is
primarily to add an ensuite bathroom to
every bedroom
and why has drawing dd submitted on the
10th of december have changes to the
seller when no changes are supposedly to
be made
this building is described in the malden
district heritage at risk register 2022
as one of the oldest and most important
houses in the town
we are in full support of renovation but
we strongly object to these proposals
that will go far beyond the needs for a
domestic dwelling
concerns over the deterioration and
condition of this building
could be addressed immediately by
replacing the left front gable ridge
tiles which were removed in february of
this year prior to the filming of the
essex serpent in march and have not been
replaced
that's our case the objectives thank you
miss woods
thank you
members you have
seen the application and you now have
the time
to debate so if i have any questions
from members for the offices
council swain
thank you madam chairman
um
refer to
the
the point on the
papers saying it is resubmitted
application
this has a a background of
an application and then a site visit
and then a consideration of it
and because of the
absences from either of the committees
or from the site visit
the numbers of people participating in
that decision was very limited however
i'm assured by
mr johnson that this has to be treated
as an entirely separate application on
its own merits
so that everybody is able to participate
in it
i
have a
rather fundamental question to ask
and a few uh additional points of
information to clear up
um my my first um
well the fundamental one is i've been
i've been trying to think why this
application and these proposals of
course so much
difficulty
and i conclude it's because what we have
here is
a domestic property that has become
a combination of domestic and commercial
over the years over the centuries even
and therefore
what we have is um
perhaps a mixed use originally which is
now treated as
entirely residential
so i would want therefore reassurance
firstly that
we are satisfied that this
um
these premises
do all satisfy the recommendation apart
from the seller um the the uh
notion of being residential and have
been used as such including these rooms
up on the upstairs of the back range um
which are supposedly bedrooms and in a
more general sense um since we're now
operating under town and planning
country planning
rules um there is no
question that somebody may
raise the whole question in future that
the occupation of all the building for
residential purposes may be unlawful
because no
change of use application has ever been
made
and
that is the general one which may be
easy to deal with
but it is a quasi-illegal one as well as
planning
um from specific points if i can address
them to the
clarification from the officer um
the um
yes um
first of all
the
rear staircase um is that it's internal
um and is entirely really to set us to
meet the um
service the upstairs of the back range
isn't it
um
is this because
access on the existing staircase really
isn't adequate
the the only other staircase being in
the
front building front part of the
building
um
secondly i i
note the point that's been made about um
the fire doors
um is this a
a matter for um for dispute or is it
entirely within the
scope of the application to include
include fire doors
subject to those points i think the
major difficulties have been dealt with
in this new proposal
and i can't therefore see any planning
reasons for
ejecting it now
hi so in regard to
the matters regarding its use
um there isn't any planning history to
indicate that it's been anything other
than residential
the layout of the property is such
would be considered residential
and
there's nothing else to indicate
otherwise
i'm just looking at
a historic application
uh which you'll find
in
uh section seven of the report on site
history
um and i can't see anything to indicate
anything other than residential
i got counsellor none i
got your hand up well just for the
record uh chairman it has been
uh things other than residential but
we're talking a long long while ago it
was a garage at one time it was a
vintness
it's been all sorts of things but we're
going back um to the 20s and
prior to the 20s into the 18th 17th 16th
centuries
but but in my lifetime it's been
residential
thank you councillor now
did you want to answer the other
questions before we go to any other
member
in relation to the internal staircase
i haven't received any um correspondence
or in writing from the conservation
officer that the
the first staircase is inadequate it's
just that they
might want to propose a second staircase
within their application i can see from
the plans that the first staircase is to
be
improved
or renovated is the word but
they haven't provided a reason as to why
there's a second staircase um it's not
something that we've requested to know
and in terms of the fire doors
the internal partitions are included
within the application and the
conservation officer has advised that
they would not impact on the
significance of the listed building
so
okay
councillor edwards
thank you man chairman um just for
clarification you mentioned that there's
no um works in the cellar but there is
there's two doors to be imported
i'm just looking at the report that says
two store doors are to be
you've got the updated report
and that's been taken out
okay thank you
um okay thank you
councillor heard
um thank you chair i'm not quite sure
why this is why we're sitting here
discussing this actually although
i understand it was through
um public concern that it's come here
and so
in another way it's a good thing that we
are
um but i could if i could just take you
to page 12
at 321
and this talks about the conclusion and
the report this proposal is supported by
both english heritage and the council's
conservation enlisted building
specialists as being exemplary proposal
for this listed building
it wouldn't uh result in any
detrimental harm to the residential
immunity of neighbouring
occupiers
i have to say
the presentation was excellent and thank
you very much indeed for that uh i'm
very impressed indeed by the plans and i
really like
what is proposed and then uh the
existing probably the best plans i've
seen actually
but i'm inclined to
agree with the officer's recommendation
and i would be happy to support that
okay thank you welcome
councillor may you put your hand up
uh yeah thank you madam chairman um i
too am very grateful for the um
the presentation which was excellent
um
i don't have any concerns with what has
been proposed and i would like to second
the motion if that was a motion put
before and think that this uh the work
that has been done
through the council with officers uh the
applicant has actually addressed all of
the members um concerns going forward uh
relating to the two staircases with a
house of such size two staircases is
really not unusual um and if i was going
from the front of the house to the back
of the house i would get fairly annoyed
if i had to go by the front staircase
rather than the back staircase
it's a large house and i think it is
entirely reasonable to actually have
another staircase
from from that area thank you thank you
councillor councillor hubner
thank you chair my main concern is the
windows
you mentioned
this some of the windows will be changed
but not all of them
so
what standard
are we applying to that
also
if the actual
seven
bedrooms were occupied
how where are they gonna park
because there's not enough space for the
vehicles to park
uh yeah
and also the fact that
fire regulations and doors are not
really in
a residential area
it strikes me that this could be
an alternative
use in the
now so
they're not using as a residential
use it's going to be let it out
okay thank you
chairman um just in relation to the
windows the ones that are not being
replaced are of
i'm not sure what date period but they
are not late modern century mate
late 20th century modern windows so
they're not being replaced the ones that
are proposed to be replaced actually
probably better to show you photographs
rather than plans
for example
these windows
you can tell are different in character
to these windows
and these are the windows this window
this are that are being replaced so
there's no significance in terms of
their loss of significance to the
historic building in terms of replacing
those windows and the ones that are of
historic significance aren't being
replaced
um in terms of parking
as discussed within the committee report
this is a domestic dwelling and
um
the bedroom
size the the number of bedrooms so three
bedrooms or more
require three parking spaces
um and
because we are actually reducing the
number of bedrooms and it's still being
above three bedrooms the parking
requirements don't change for this
application obviously if a change of use
that requires planning permission was to
occur we would need to look at parking
but that would be as part of a separate
application
and in terms of fire doors again we're
not looking at the change of the use of
the property as part of this application
so that's not consideration under this
application
that's okay
is there any other questions can
counselor seance
uh
thank you chair it's not a question i
would just like to concur um with other
councillors here this evening that
concerns um have been addressed
which
i'm thankful
and
and i would be prepared to
accept this application thank you thank
you councillor edwards
all right i was just like uh just like
to concur as well because this property
needs renovation urgently because
to stop it deteriorating any further
having been there myself thank
do i have
councillor swine
yes chairman if i just um at one comment
um
reflecting um back to the
sense of grievance that um um a lot of
people um
seem to feel about uh the
difficulties of getting uh any changes
made to
um their buildings on conservation
grounds
i think there are questions to be asked
about how
much work has been done on this
property um without perhaps planning
application without planning commission
but i think that's uh not for this forum
that's for some other
kind
okay thank you
is there any other
questions for
the members of the committee councillor
shaughnessy
yes if you'll excuse me chair i did
forget to um
express a non-pecuniary interest as i do
know ms woods
and i forgot at the time i do apologize
thank you chair
thank you
councillor hood
um
thank you chair well in that case i'd
like to make a proposal that we accept
the officer's recommendation thank you
and councilman do you still want to
second that
yes i will second that thank you thank
you
so there is a proposal to accept the
officer's recommendation it has been
seconded by councillor mays can i ask
all councillors
in favor
of this proposal
so that's
all councillors are in favor of this
proposal all against
and councillor hubner you are against
this proposal
okay thank you officers
uh members that has
thank you officers as well thank you for
your presentation
uh thank you members that has now passed
so this um proposal has been accepted
item 5 any other items of business that
the chairman decides are urgent there
are none
so item a is the closure of meeting
members thank you for your contributions
this evening i now draw the meeting to a
close at
eight o'clock
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion and please leave the meeting
by the exit door behind the top table
bearing in mind social distancing thank
you